foreign
Alabama Elise from Facebook has a
question for us what are the phases we
go through when getting to know someone
and how do we avoid moving too fast if
there's a strong Chemistry Between Us
can we talk a bit about attachment
Styles because I think this may be the
one area where we disagree
and it's mainly although I probably
agree with the essence of what we're
talking about here but to me as soon as
I began to wake up in my right around
age 39 or 40. I understood
all of the problems with attachment and
attachment being the main roadblock
toward love for me because I was really
attaching myself not just just to a
person although I've attached myself to
20 people but also a particular outcome
with that person yeah and it strikes
back to a question earlier that we were
talking about uh being attracted to to
someone but then we also are attracted
to this ideal version of someone it's
not I'm not attracted to my wife I'm
attracting my wife if she does these 14
things in this sequence and continues to
do them and oh by the way as soon as she
meets those I'll Heap on three more
expectations for some reason I'm never
happy now with the the relationship and
then it gets back to those three words
that you ended that beautiful reading
with we want out and we tend to want out
because of well because of these
attachments that we've we've tethered
our our happiness to um oh I guess I
could say so much about this I mean this
is this idea that we have decided that
our partners are just these need meeting
machines that they need to do all of
these things to meet our needs and if
they're not meeting their needs it's
them and something's wrong with the
relationship right rather than owning I
have needs and many of those needs are
actually my responsibility to meet and I
can have honest conversation with my
partner obviously about my needs but the
expectations feel a little bit different
to me than necessarily attachment only
when we're talking about attachment as
attachment like Theory right so I I kind
of want to say let's separate out the
idea of expectation from attachment now
attachment to outcome to me is an
expectation sure right attachment and
attachment Theory feels a little bit
different and so I'm going to quote
um Gabor mate so he talks about how
every single human that comes into this
onto this plane has two needs the need
for attachment and the need for autonomy
okay the thing is is that at the end of
the day attach meant will win out
because attachment is what we need to
survive so as a baby we have to attach
to our primary caregivers in order to
survive right so what do I do I learn
how to mold myself into what they like
and they need to please them because I
need that positive regard I need that
kind of Joyful connection that love
right so we learn these things very
early on I do still need autonomy those
two things will transfer into adulthood
but at the end of the day attachment I
have learned I can die without it and so
without really examining where why how
those attachment patterns start to form
unconsciously I'm going to revert back
to attachment being the primary thing
that motivates me in relationship
because it's attached to survival now
it's not as an adult if I don't meet
John's attachment needs right I'm not
gonna die he's not gonna die but very
unconsciously at a very deep level I
believe that I will unless I've done the
examining and I can call that out for
what it is right so I just want to I
want to say like I do do think we need
to say attachment and expectation might
be a little bit different at least in
this context and yet it's possible to
transcend that type of attachment as
well when you start to understand it for
what it is and in fact teenagers begin
to understand this because that's when
they become unattached or they actually
try to detach which is different yeah
and so it's you've had this need this
attachment because you are literally
surviving based on your attachment to
your parents but at some point you're
able to survive on your own and then you
always do the thumbing your nose thing
which is the autonomy yes that's where
autonomy comes into play usually is in
adolescence yes and yet as we become
adults now we pick up these new
attachments we think they're going to
help us survive right but they actually
get in the way of our freedom and you
know examples are the white picket fence
the big house the nice car the car loan
the you know thousand dollar suits or
whatever they are right all of nothing
inherently wrong with these things but
if we think this is what makes me me me
who I am this is my identity our second
book Everything That Remains the first
line of it is our identities are shaped
by the costumes we wear
quite often we try to Adorn ourselves
with literal costumes a suit or I'm this
type of person or this type of car this
type of house because we're afraid of
what's going on in here
um is that why you wear black by the way
um
attachment Styles not in the sense of
Buddhism and getting hooked but in
wiring due to how we were raised and how
that affects relationships so I'm
avoidantly attached she's uh I'm anxious
wait a second are you I mean new news to
me I'm anxiously attached she's a uh
more on the avoidance dip into it and of
course we've done a lot of work
everywhere everyone's trying to swim
towards secure
um but me being anxious uh comes out in
me wanting to hold her leg or she needs
to tell me five times a day that she's
attracted to me right having that sense
of you know needing that her avoidance
is when I do that she runs the other way
right so just being aware of our default
where it comes from and then the work is
like you said now that I'm aware of this
what does it look like to sit with it or
whatever it needs for you to
run the other way and so you're more
securely attached what are these
different attachment Styles can we for
our listeners
there's four that are the primary right
so they're secure which is really the
one everybody wants to move towards then
we've got avoidant we've got anxious and
we've got anxiously oh my God I just
blanked out disorganized disorganized
sorry so those were the four I was like
I'm a therapist I swear
there's disorganized attachments so uh
within an anxious attachment it is the
kind of constant desire and need for
that external sense of like I am okay I
am here I am needed I am necessary and
so we're constantly seeking that
external right that's what soothes my
anxiety okay which is what this idea all
is based on
um avoidance is really I too much
closeness actually makes like my sense
of self get snuffed out by too much
closeness and so in order to protect
against that I put up that wall I back
up I you know that's the avoiding right
and then disorganized usually comes to
play when there's a little bit of both
and usually disorganized is really Trace
to real trauma like rooted in severe
trauma and upbringing parents who are
completely incapable of meeting your
attachment needs for a variety of
reasons we'll tend to see people falling
disorganized secure the percentage of
secure is actually really low only
because we do tend to swing so we can
actually show up differently in
different relationships I've been in
relationships with people who are more
avoidant and I tend to be a little bit
more anxious right and so it does tend
to be like what you trigger in me I
respond in kind the reason why we talk
about it in the book is because we have
seen so often in our clients this idea
of opposites attract
his anxious triggers in me my avoidance
it makes sense to us that unconsciously
we would be drawn to each other because
that's just another layer of healing
that we actually need to do and he's
providing me with and I am providing him
with an opportunity to heal those wounds
if we look at it that way yeah and her
avoiding puts a black light on my ages
right
you could either look at it and say okay
here's the prescription or you could not
look at it and date the same person and
relationships keep going the same and
just be activated all of the time
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100
advertisement free